[Music]
if you if you want to make nearly your
life then fox is the best tool
for a while he's kind of like like all
those characters evil characters the
best character that gave an
undefeatable fox has the best shield
pressure approach and ko moves in the
entire game
the year is 20xxx everyone plays fox
you can kind of play whatever game you
want to play with him
you just do stuff really fast and it
feels like you have complete control
nice down hey to save himself just for
that one situation
and there it is the up smash 3-1 mango
has come
all the way back losers back uh
he's sick
[Music]
but yeah as i was saying before you put
together the sick
combo to end game two wow
definitely and just oh my god oh my god
get
off the stage
[Applause]
going up against fox isn't easy but you
know what is
switching to geico 15 minutes could save
you
15 or more on car insurance check out
the link in the description below for
more information
now back to the story of fox
[Music]
fox mcleod was always destined to be god
tier
originally modeled after inari a
japanese fox god the character was
created for a 1993
snes game called star fox his time in
that game and its sequels
led fox to develop a cult following and
by 1999 he was popular enough to find
himself alongside some of nintendo's
most popular characters
and super smash brothers 64. introducing
super smash brothers where all your
favorite characters go toe-to-toe
in one four-player star-studded slam
fest only on nintendo 64.
while smash was a mega success for
nintendo fox found himself living in the
shadows of other characters in the
game's cast
but that all changed in 2001 when
nintendo released super smash brothers
melee
a title that brought speed to the
forefront of its gameplay
and being one of the game's fastest
characters capable of both attacking and
recovering quickly
fox established himself as one of the
most efficient killers in the game
playing fox you know you have one of the
biggest tool sets in the whole game
depending on your style of play you can
adapt it adapt his tool kit however you
like
you've seen players be successful uh
with a brush down style as well
as a zoning or more patient platform
based style so his versatility is
probably his
biggest strength he he gets messed up
really hard if
he gets hit he just gets destroyed but
you can just do stuff really fast and it
feels like
you have complete control as well but
despite having the ingredients for being
the best character in the game
fox still had a long way to go for
several years the top honor belonged to
sheik
and the advantages of one character over
the other were often contested among the
pros
while there were several notable players
like chilendude and musashi who were
pushing fox's limits
other characters saw more success in
tournament settings
[Applause]
despite falling short during the early
days of competitive melee fox remained
an enticing challenge for players
he was an extremely technical character
one who demanded serious dedication and
a whole lot of practice in order to
master
and while his speed combos and damage
output gave him an edge over pretty much
every other character in the game he
also proved to be a bit of a gamble
[Applause]
right
he kind of just dies no matter what no
matter what you get hit by you just
kind of dies and that can be frustrating
sometimes if you're not playing well
but luckily he has tools to allow you to
kind of work around and play different
styles so that it's not
as volatile and it doesn't as easily get
like
hit it doesn't as easily get opened up
in spite of the glaring weaknesses in
his kit
for those willing to put in the work fox
was a treasure trove of
untapped potential and in 2004 players
like zelgattus began to unleash it in
ways no one thought were
possible yeah a video like shineblind
came out a little
bit before i got in the scene but by
then it was already one of the most
popular videos to show new players
because this was 2005 and just that use
of
shine in particular was not apparent to
a casual player
playing back then so it seemed like a
really flashy play style
uh but you know also great combos great
music like all the old dbr videos
uh so i actually think shine's blind
even holds up
somewhat to this day the melee community
continued to find new ways to utilize
fox and by mid-2006
with the emergence of players like
mewtwo king pc chris and korean dj
fox was finally getting the recognition
he deserved
all right let's see with the whole stock
advantage dj laying on the on right here
right here and
really really really nice ledge guarding
there it goes yeah
right there marine dj's edge guarding up
missing with the ford b and there it is
of smash pc
has won congratulations to pc chris
it was in july of that year that fox was
finally able to bump
chic from the top spot and claim the
melee throne for the first time
but it wasn't long before he found
jigglypuff and falcomanes nipping at his
heels
punch him in the face
[Applause]
go
[Applause]
fox had fallen into a rut and players
began to recognize that the only way to
get him out of it
was to dig deeper that meant looking for
new
innovative ways to increase shield
pressure and improve his close range
fighting mechanics
and with so many world-class players
throwing themselves behind the cause
foxplay ascended to a whole new level
pressure
that was sexy mango covered too many
options
he's feeling himself done he is trying
to win this tournament three stocks
okay guys we're going to go down to the
wire
[Applause]
fox's dominance became so prevalent that
it even gave life to a community meme
known as 20xx a post-apocalyptic future
in which you'd have
no choice but to main fox hacks aziz is
this running joke about um
you see you know in mega man like in the
mega man show it's like the year is 20
xx yeah
yeah so is he as easy as the year is 20
xx
everyone plays fox there's this whole
like post-apocalyptic universe that is
built
off of like fox being the only viable
character left yeah
and no one demonstrated the terrifying
potential of 20xx
better than mango whose wins at evo 2013
and 2014 cemented fox's position as the
king
of melee oh good block and then here
comes the throw and again
avoiding it oh fairly bad illusion
oh nice down a to save himself just from
that one situation
but still and there it is the up smash
and wobbles is gonna go down
three one mango has come all the way
back
train and make go why not take it yet he
goes for the upper throw up here
this time it hits and we have our
champion mango
first place here at evolution 2014 for
super smash brothers
melee singles around this time
fox was the number one choice for more
than half of the top 20 players
but that's not to say that all fox mains
were created equal
players like armada leffen and mango
took fox's skill ceiling and
elevated it beyond what most could ever
hope to achieve
and as the mechanical expertise of the
top level competitors ramped up so did
the physical demands playing fox placed
on them
and anyone hoping to reach the elite
ranks of melee
hacks the man behind 20xx was considered
one of the most technically gifted foxes
on the planet
but that mastery came at the cost of his
hands by
a normal person's standards my left hand
and wrists are in very bad
shape but by my standards they're fine
meaning like i can get i can do
everything i want to do basically
i can i can game no problem um
with the box you know with my custom
controller i
can no longer use an analog stick for
example so
if i wanted to play this game uh the
traditional way i wouldn't be able to do
that
uh i also have very weak
wrist flexion because they had to remove
a
flexor tendon from my wrist and that
comes with pretty severe uh
repercussions but i accepted them
because it had to be done
hax made the switch from captain falcon
to fox exacerbating a pre-existing
condition to the point where he had to
undergo
many surgeries and take a lengthy hiatus
from melee
the way i saw it i was this player who
had so much untapped potential and so
much left to prove
like i really felt like if i had one
more year of playing fox i felt i felt
like i
would have been the best in the world
but then all this hand stuff happened
and then we were just left wondering
what what could have been hax's
predicament drew the community's
attention towards just how grueling the
grind could be
and in melee the quest for perfecting
fox might be the most
punishing example of that grind but
you know it does take a toll on your
hands which
potentially makes you able to practice
less and definitely makes you less
consistent in tournament
under pressure game five i was dealing
with this for like
years at least the wrist stuff and um
i tried everything dude like i went to
physical therapy
i tried like all these different
exercises stretches and that might have
given like
temporary relief same with my leg like
physical therapy
didn't really help me at all but in
spite of the risk that fox poses to
players
he has never lost their favor up smash
does not knock down falcon if he's at
zero
right but if you get one oh my god oh
man what a shot what a shine
wow okay but yeah as i was saying before
ibw's put together the
sick combo to end game two wow he caught
his jump and he got the up here
dude what the [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ]
dude what the [ __ ]
i'm wrong with that controller blazers
in his face i love the way fat goku
plays
up there oh wow shine backer is going to
take the first game it looks like the
fact that oh my god
yo got a second game i'm sorry gets a
little uh
a little custom on the on the last stock
there okay i think
moki is playing out of spine right now
ice though with the edges
that number is not gonna last that much
longer
fox being the most common character in
both doubles and singles for many years
added another unique challenge for those
looking to main them
in terms of technical expertise he's
basically been figured out
but if tech was all fox had to offer
he'd never
have reached his iconic status in melee
yeah i think as far as
a specific tech skill uh options
uh most of fox i feel like has been
figured out
people like hacks and leffen kjh have
really
labbed the character out to a great
degree but as far as strategy
goes and how you can employ your tech
skill in a match i
really think fox has a really long way
to go still
no matter what the future holds fox's
impact on the game is
undeniable he's become such a staple
knowing how to use him is a must for top
level players
i think like 40 of the top 20 plays him
or at least secondary sims so no matter
who's at the top that's going to be
a gigantic part of the game fox has
become the face of competitive melee
and it's characteristic fast style of
play yeah i think fox is just so iconic
in melee because he's one of the
characters that represents
the extremely fast gameplay that melee
can offer
as well as the wide range of technical
options
a lot of characters can do that in melee
but fox seems to exemplify it the most
he set the bar for what is possible in
the game but his toolkit's amazing he's
extremely fast
and you can kind of play whatever game
you want to play with him
and it's almost always a plan that's at
least
somewhat capable of winning he defined
the divide between
competitive and casual play you will be
punished hard every single time you make
a mistake
which makes him quite bad at low level
he's basically for top level only but if
you want to
if you have dreams of being like the
best player in the world then there's a
great character invested but most
importantly
he created plenty of role models for the
next generation
a lot of stuff you can do with this
character that hasn't been done yet
eight percent
absolutely tearing through everyone
today tope
leffen is our evo 2018 super smash
brothers melee champion
hello ben
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you